hello everyone I hope you're all having
a great Saturday and also the weekend so
too with today's uploads I'm hoping to
finish car post cards amazing run inland
RS 1994
this is round five of this of the super
tournament in Linares Karpov already
defeated Cordoba he defeated the bereave
in the second round he made his immortal
game against Apollo in round three he
defeated a lot here in round four and
this is round five he's playing against
the fourteen-year-old I believe it she
was 14 at that time you did bogar and
it's very instructive
although polgár was only 14 years old
she was already known to be a tall like
aggressive player so it's very
interesting how Karpov counts the game
down from from the very beginning of the
game so let's see this positional
masterpiece Karpov Karpov created Karpov
has the white pieces and he plays efore
and we have c5 by young unit c3 Karpov
avoids the main line of the Sicilian as
well a c3 is a much more common approach
to the Sicilian defense we have e six in
d4 d5 by unit he capture 75e capture 75
and Knight to f3 and as you can see this
is something carpel often does in his
games at some point he will be able to
capture d captures on c5 create an
isolated D pawn and will well try try
and make this game all about this
isolated D pawn Knight to c6
Karpov goes for Bishop to b5 pinning the
night and here we have an interesting
move by unit she plays c4 she doesn't
allow Karpov to capture D captures on c5
and create an this isolated deep bond
which is an interesting move but this
will be well it will be positionally
better for white you a carpet will
undermine it later with a move like b3
we have nice to e5 now already
threatening and Knight captures on c6
with Bishop captures on c6 polgár
defends this with a Queen to b6 and we
have Bishop captures on c6 with check B
captures on c6
Karp of castles we have Bishop to d6 and
immediately carpal goes for b3 with the
idea of B captures on c4
we have seek after some b3 in our carpet
plays a capture some B 3 and our Karpov
has this very powerful rook on a1 and
this isolated a pawn will not be a
target for the rest of the game Knight
to e7 preparing to castle and we have
Bishop to a3 and well this is a very
annoying move as Karpov would like to
exchange these dark squared Bishop
bishops and he will be left with this
amazing knight on e5 and it will it
won't be that easy to get rid of it so
instead of doing this unit decides to
capture this knight on e5 with Bishop
captures on e5 we have D captures on e5
and now Karpov is left with this wall
beautifully strong bishop on a3 and it's
impossible for you to castle now
immediately Karpov sorry unit goes for
Bishop 3 6 and Queen to d4 carpel Karpov
offers the exchange of Queens as he will
now make this game entirely about the
dark squares as he is the only person
with the dark squares and you did slight
square Bishop isn't really able able to
confront him Knight to a5 attacking
Karpov Queen and Karpov goes Queen to c5
still offering a trade of Queens oh of
course he does the heat the Karpov
doesn't want to capture the screen and
b6 this would allow a capture some b6
fixing vulgar spawn structure and also a
TV activating the black rook on a8 and
now well our poker has this very strong
night and f5 Karpov would really enjoy
dislodging it from there with a move
like g4
so Pagar stops this with a move like H
five nice to d2 by Karpov and we have f6
now making room for the for King to
escape on f7 and if Karpov decides to
capture on f6 this will open up the G
file and vulgar will be able to maybe
make some kind of an attack but Karpov
isn't worried he plays he captures and
f6g captures on f6 and Bishop to b4
we have King to f7 rook to a4 and Karpov
is ready to double up on the a file to
really go for this a seven point support
guard decides the Tradewinds Queen
captures on c5 Bishop captures on c5 and
we have a six now maybe maybe allowing
Bishop to ch2 to defend this pawn on a6
f3 and this f3 move is is a good move by
Karpov he is making room for Ace King to
go to F 2 so the rook can either go to
e1 a1 or if polgár plays something like
rook to g8 the rook can also come to g1
to defend this pawn we have H for
preparing for a move like h3 and our
rook F to a-1 doubling up on the a file
and going for this a6 pawn bishop to c8
defending it and the King to have to now
h3 isn't really any any sort of a threat
because simply g3 and this is a
perfectly fine structure for white rook
to b8 and we have before now completely
locking the dark squares and well Pagar
isn't gonna have a lot of fun playing
this position rook to e8 getting getting
her rook on an open file and Knight to
b3 and the well now Karpov has some
ideas of Knight to a5 going for this c6
pawn nice to d4 would also be an
excellent square for the knight to go
for the c6 point from d4 although he
will first have to push g4 and after H
capture some pass on and H captures
energy and only then push g4 but this
night it will not stay on f5 forever so
Bishop to b7 adding protection to this
e6 pawn but on the other hand this is
making this light square bishop well as
strong as a pawn if you look at this
light square bishop it's it's even worse
than a pawn and Karpos dark square
Bishop is really well probably the most
powerful piece on the board so we have a
nice to a5 attacking this Bishop on b7
that is that's defending the a and C
pawn bishop to a 8 and the Karpov plays
rook
- eh - now preparing the go to the
e-file with both visit works rook to e6
unit also preparing to double up on the
e-file and now a very very ingenious
maneuver by Karpov he plays at Bishop to
a7 attacking this row can be 8 and he
wants to force this rock away from the B
file for example if if something like
rook rook B to e8 displayed then then
this Knights to b3 would really be an
annoying move for polgár as now this
rook would be immediately attacking this
a sex pawn and there is also the threat
of night to c5 that wouldn't attack on
the rook and the a6 bond
so instead after this Bishop to a7 move
polgár makes really really a weird move
it's a bold move but it's really an anti
positional move she plays a rook to b5
and this is pretty much locking her rook
on b5 for the rest of the game and well
who better to take advantage of this
then Anatoly Karpov Karpov plays Knight
to b3 we have Bishop to b7 now again
adding protection to the a6 pawn g4 by
Karpov we have H capture son g4 h
capture son g3 Karpov is of course
preparing G for rook to e8 because while
the threat was g4 and Knights to d4 I
would have fork on both rooks so Pagar
moves the rook rook to e8 we have g4
attacking the knight Knight to d6 and
the Karpov simply plays Knight to d4 and
in this position unit polgár resigned
the game as well this rook has nowhere
to go that's why it was it was a bold
move but a completely empty anti
positional move Karpov is winning the
exchange and well although she young
uses Bolger was a very ferocious player
she doesn't want to play against Anatoly
Karpov being the exchange down so yeah
that's the game Karpov is 5 out of 5 he
will continue to win all of his games it
will take Alex a sheriff to stop him in
round
but only with a draw and well I will
post one more game from Anatoly Karpov
and with this game I will probably
finish with Dylan RS tournament
regarding Karpov I was gonna I was gonna
upload his game against wisely von
Schuch and it's it's really a great game
but it ends by eventual bond during the
piece so I decided not to show this if
you would like to maybe I will but I
think I will show some other game so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Tony
more what guitar for a contribution to
my channel think a lot sir I really
appreciate it as usual you can check
though my previous videos here thank all
for watching and I will see you soon